hallo leute nach langer zeit machen wir
heute wieder eine neue episode kari
antwortet heute gibt es keine untertitel
aber ich versuche langsam und deutlich
zu sprechen warum beantworten wir heute
fragen ihr habt letztens eine neue
episode gesehen und das thema war was
berliner an berlin hassen oder nicht
mögen und dort gab es ein kontroverses
thema viele berliner eigentlich nur drei
haben gesagt dass sie touristen nicht
mögen und in unseren kommentaren gab es
einen shitstorm viele von euch haben
gesagt warum und diese kommentare
beantworten wird jetzt lesen wir mal ein
paar kommentare marie moon schreibt ich
habe nicht verstanden warum die berliner
touristen nicht mögen
das haben viele nicht verstanden ich
auch noch nicht so ganz
quincy morris schreibt und was soll ich
sagen über die tausenden deutschen die
mein land besuchen
gute frage deutsche touristen sind auch
nicht überall gern gesehen
aber weil du deutsch lernst zumindest
schätze ich das denn du guckst ja unser
video sagst du einfach hier hoch und
obst ein deutschland ihnen frieda
schreibt berliner mögen uns nicht ich
werde niemals nach berlin fahren ich
möchte nicht zu einem platz fahren wo
die menschen uns nicht mögen
das ist natürlich eine berechtigte sorge
dass ihr jetzt nach berlin kommt und die
leute euch nicht mögen aber ich kann
euch beruhigen so schlimm ist das nicht
berliner sind generell und freundlich
also sie mögen auch sich selbst nicht
aber es ist nicht so dass sie alle
unfreundlich sind zu allen touristen im
gegenteil
dr ordnern schreibt ich bin überrascht
weil viele leute geantwortet haben dass
sie die touristen hassen aber nicht
mögen
ich fand das nicht gut das kann ich
verstehen dass ich fand das auch nicht
gut
ich fand das auch ein bisschen
unfreundlich und ihr habt ein iranisches
reaktionen video gesehen dass er auch
überrascht war dass viele leute gesagt
haben
ich mag die touristen nicht das ist ja
auch irgendwie eine komische reaktion
gomez familie schreibt all of your own
the people in der street view century
dankeschön days in paradise valley nasa
grumpy but that is something that
happens in evry big city life wird hier
new york paris berlin has the people of
the city and many of you and i love you
because we all know that i'm sorry for
some people for nature of space bei
business school city that nobody wants
to miss it das fand ich einen sehr
schönen kommentar von gomis familie
du hast es genau auf den punkt getroffen
girardot francis schreibt german tour is
everywhere way of travel betont andy
mann ist er ist in der country what the
is aba fischer wenn man als
londoner oder als florentiner oder
pariser nach berlin kommt so als tourist
denkt man ja eher wie ruhig und
gemütlich ist es hier im vergleich denn
wir haben natürlich die berliner
touristen mal 10
aber man nörgelt eben gern das haben die
berliner und die londoner gemeinsam
und genau so würde ich das auch sehen
berliner meckern gerne dass es generell
so es gibt auch viel wandel in der stadt
das darf man nicht vergessen vor 30
jahren war berlin quasi ein also eine
geschlossene stadt mit mauern drinnen
und drum herum und es gab wenig leute
überhaupt in berlin und plötzlich sind
ganz viele leute gekommen
ich habe mal die touristenzahlen
nachgeguckt berlin ist gewachsen in den
letzten jahren und es sind auch es
kommen immer mehr touristen in die stadt
berlin hat jetzt fast vier millionen
einwohner und 2000 vor zehn jahren hatte
es sieben millionen touristen
mittlerweile hat es doppelt so viele ich
glaube 14 15 millionen touristen und 13
millionen touristen jedes jahr das ist
natürlich viel und vielleicht könnt ihr
auch verstehen es gibt manche orte die
sich einfach rasant schnell verändern wo
es jede woche neue geschäfte gibt neue
neue läden aufmachen manche kneipen sind
plötzlich völlig überfüllt und ich merke
das auch an der stelle wo wir leben
manchmal gibt es dort so viele pubs weil
gerade ganz viele besoffene touristen
durch die stadt sehen dass wir einfach
mitten in der nacht super viel krawall
vor der tür haben und dann denke ich
manchmal auch scheiß touris aber das
heißt natürlich nicht dass ich keine
touristen mag und dass ich nicht
freundlich zu ihnen bin
es kommt immer darauf an wer kommt und
wie er sich benimmt
also habt bitte keine angst kommt nach
berlin wir heißen euch willkommen und
wenn ihr ja nun schon mich auf der
straße sieht dann sagt ein freudiges
hallo wir freuen uns euch zu sehen
ich wollte noch eine abmoderation
hinzufügen
fabian ist leider unter schreiend
zusammen gebrochen jannis kannst du das
noch mal machen
also das war unser video für heute wir
hoffen ihr habt alles verstanden ohne
untertitel und wir möchten euch jetzt
noch einladen unsere app sieht lang
auszuprobieren bei siegling könnt ihr
grammatik lernen mit unserem content wie
ihr könnt über 4.500 vokabeln lernen und
in regelmäßigen abständen trainieren und
seit letzter woche haben wir auch ein
thriller game das heißt ihr könnt mit
einem quiz mit einem interaktiven spiel
deutsch lernen probiert das nur aus wir
freuen uns sehr wenn die app nützlich
für euch ist lasst uns einen kommentar
und danke schön und bis nächste woche
guten tag guten tag ich erzähle die
einen witz zu dunkel dort zu hell der
umwerfen